Much like ranking ranking pain, I want you to think about ranking gains.
And so, think about it and make a list of what each gain your products and services create
according to its relevance to the customer.
This is the big idea--the relevance to the customer because much like in pain,
you're going to make your first list thinking you got it.
Here is what I'm going to solve for pain and here is what I'm going to create for gain.
I absolutely know this--"Why?" because it's my opinion or I might have been a domain expert,
but you know what at the end of the day your business isn't about your opinion.
What you need to do is now hear this from customers who say, "Here is why it's relevant."
And much like pain, you want to understand--is this a substantial or insignificant gain created
and again understand the frequency that it occurs.